et tout de suite antoine claireaux
depuis moscou notre correspondant
antoine comment se concrétise ce
cessez-le-feu et bien dès les premières
heures de la matinée quasiment
immédiatement après la déclaration de
vladimir poutine
ormes et matériels ont commencé à être
déployés vers le haut karabagh dans le
cadre d'une mission de maintien de la
paix je vous propose d'écouter la
déclaration d'un responsable militaire
russe en charge de cette mission
notre brigade est spécial elle se
focalise sur le maintien de la paix le
plan d'entraînement militaire de la
brigade comprend une formation aux
opérations de maintien de la paix dans
les zones de conflit comme le service au
poste d'observation aux points de
contrôle et la surveillance des cessez
le feu et des hostilités notre brigade
n'a que des soldats sous contrat ce sont
tous de bons spécialistes prêts à
accomplir tout ce qu'il faut dans le
cadre de cette mission et en vertu du
texte signé par les dirigeants russes
arméniens et azerbaïdjanais
ce sont près de 2000 soldats 90
véhicules blindés et 380 autres
véhicules qui seront déployés le long de
la ligne de contact et du couloir entre
le haut karabagh et l'arménie proprement
dit
cessez le feu est donc entré en vigueur
dans la nuit quelques heures seulement
après que l'hélicoptère russe a été
abattu par l'azerbaïdjan en territoire
armin cette trêve est censé mettre fin
aux six semaines de combats dans cette
région alors que les forces
azerbaïdjanaises vous l'avez évoqué
avait progressé de façon significative
ces derniers jours donc l'hérault en
direct de moscou donc